大家好 我是阿瑟 艾莉斯
歡迎參加我的實戰經濟辦的課程
今天當然
哪些操作的課題呢 我們來看下去
短線操作的技巧
那短線操作技巧 我們要先了解什麼
交易時期的概念
好 那我們交易時期
其實一天大概分三個主要的時段
分一從
九上的九點到十點半
十點半到十二點 又是五盤的時間啦
從十二點到一點三十分
又是進入到尾盤的時段
那請問呢
一天當中最主要的交易時間的波動
主要都發生在哪裡呢
發生在我們
早盤的時段
其實早盤時段一天當中最主要的波動
不論是股票也好 企業也好
一天當中最主要的波動都發生早盤
所以你會發現到什麼狀況呢
就是早上的高低點
就早上最高
我們Day High
或是我們所謂Day Low
大概70%到80%的機率
都出現了早盤
所以你要掌握一天中最主要波動
一定出現早盤
那五盤這個時間呢
或是尾盤的時間呢
基本上那是做調整用
為什麼
哇不如一許啊
今天開高走低
我趕快賣掉
或者今天很棒
看尾盤我再趕快撿便宜
趕快做進場
所以五盤跟尾盤是做調整用
可是如果現在做強勢股
那今天開盤之後
走勢是強勢弱
其實大多數的時間
早盤就做一個確定了
所以我今天要做進場
其實早盤的時間非常非常黃金
非常非常關鍵
好
這個是一檔股票的走勢
其實我們今天看它是強
看它是弱
其實它早盤的時間
這個看出端倪有沒有
這是早盤時間
我們剛剛看到它的例子
來我們大概用紅色的筆來看一下
來這是早盤時間
早盤是10點半
對不對
早上看相對高
它就往上走了
是主要波動 10點就沒了
10點半 這邊一灘死水
主要波動在10點半之前 早盤時間就沒了
好 那我們再來看下個例子
來 這個空方走勢
早盤的時間我們就看得出來它趨向怎麼走
開相對高的往下走
對 開相對高
開盤開296.5 最高298
開相對高的往下走了
好 我再看下個例子
來 這更明顯了
什麼意思
為什麼今天一開盤
就這樣稀哩話拉往下走
為什麼 早盤在告訴你呢早盤時間告訴你呢今天直接開165.5最高166.5
開相對高也是往下殺
對不對
所以這找盤的時候
他就盤面上透露出非常非常多的訊息
好來
那我們再做個極短線的操作
事實上有時候根本連K棒都不用看
請問剛剛我們看任何的K棒
有沒有看1分K 3分K 5分K
什麼K棒都沒有看
我們只是看盤中江波走勢圖
所以做短線操作
也說單量比1分K的反應更加重要
極短線他只能做什麼
Tick a Tray
只能做Tick a Tray
所以重點都是出大量
尤其做低短線的操作
我覺得是看單量會比看K棒來的更加重要
比如說
如果你看做極短線當充
有時候這個
成交單量 成交明細的畫面
會比1分K走四處更加重要
所以整個畫面都是做密碼
成交明細喔
來
所以有時候你發現
當他成交量有時候出現爆大量
尤其請問這什麼股票
這高價股還是低價股
高價股300多塊股票
你會發現這邊爆出28張
58張
一張30多塊的股票高價股
結果高價股是誰在玩的
賞戶玩的嗎
不是
大戶有錢人在玩的
當他敢買敢敲大單的時候有沒有
这边同个时间这么多张敲下去
加起来100多张
同个时间 几乎都同个时间
在接近尾盘的时候 请问谁在买的
这边是个秘诀 这一套学起来
免费教你就可以赚到很多钱 为什么
敢在尾盘敲进去 请问
这些人是要赚怎样的钱
你在尾盘敲进去是要赚什么钱
你在尾盘快收盘了
最近是尾盘时间12点半
他赚什么钱
是要赚隔天开高的钱
是要赚隔日充的钱
对不对
有时候尾盘做调整嘛
对
他敢在7%的时候去买
去拉到涨停板赚什么
赚这一%的钱
明天赌开高嘛
所以这些筹码是非常稳定的
所以你当年可以赚这张价差
运气好拉涨停
隔天开高
他就赚这些隔日充的人的钱
这正常的隔日充的人
他是这样
是尾盘进场
隔天找盘就做粗调
所以我们再这样看下去
有沒有
他一路拉
請問剛剛是買多少
可是買了306吧
一路拉拉拉拉拉拉拉
拉到307号大單
然後再一路拉拉拉拉拉拉拉
這邊拉到308拉到308309這邊才開始有些賣單单卖单的出现了这边我换另外一个例子有没有发现这边尾盘才有大单敢拉上去
一点才拉上去的
请问这边敢再涨7% 8%拉上去的
赚什么钱
就刚刚讲的状况
隔日冲的筹码进去了
有没有百元以上高价股
所以敢賺這個7%
明天要拼什麼
拼開高的
這時候你要不要跟
要跟
他敢進去所長廳
明天就拼開高
所以他隔天啊
來
隔天存存狀況
開高高
隔天開高
當天收133
隔天開133
當場賺3%
前一天已經拉尾盤已經賺2%
隔天開會再算少 總共賺5%
所以隔日聰現賺5%
所以他每次這樣做 隔日聰5% 5% 5%
他就積少成多 他就賺錢了
隔日聰這樣賺錢喔 所以這樣子
記起來是口訣 你就賺錢了
出量拉回做極短線
跟隔日聰勝率很高
所以如果你是個股期勒
不要小看就5% 6%喔
如果你是做個股期勒
做5% 10% 你就可以賺多少錢了
我們里周有某個同仁
這幾天靠這樣子
就賺了8萬10萬了
三天的對上單
群組都有貼單
你都可以看得到
也是百元以上的那個高架股
來
那我們看盤畫面
我建議你這樣設置
這邊是盤中左字圖
我沒有用到任何K線
有沒有發現
剛剛看都沒有任何K線
這盤中左字圖成交明細
這裡放閃電下單截
如果你習慣看五檔掛單
你可以開兩個
一个放现股的散登下单
一个放个股期的下单夹
一个放现股的
一个放那个个股期的下单夹
好
那如果你想看老师
我不想做极短线的
我想做日内波段的
ok
你可以参加我们的课程
可以解锁更多画面
我告诉你说我们看几分k
我们这设计是怎样参数
设计是怎样均线的那个参数
甚至弄怎样的指标
ok
那我们我们的课程
会给你解锁更多
我盘中转强转强
看哪些美美的杠杠
ok 甚至轉弱是看哪些妹妹嘎嘎
ok 然后近期熱門股
比如說當時我們怎麼做台藥
台藥轉強之後看長這麼大
這麼長一段ok 然后之後我們做某檔股票哇塞 長這麼多對不對那對賬單也貼給你看真的人家扎實三天
就賺了8萬塊
對不對
他說感謝這支貢獻
對賬單也貼給你看了
這也貼到你群裡面
對 人家扎實的靠這支短線當中這樣做來做去
好 那哪些東西是我們這門課必學的
其實
你找盤關盤的重點
盤中轉強轉弱這兩個壁學
為什麼
哪些股票建議研判
可能早上可能9點15分之後
開高走低
或者說開低走高
盤中轉強轉弱這兩個壁學
剛才有講過的是極短線當中技巧
哪些拉尾盤
可以做隔日沖
這些是壁學
甚至掛下技巧
我建議開盤如何
已經占到便宜
對 比如早上我要開盤要出
怎麼掛價技巧就賺到那個2 3%的這個
這個價差 這些就避雪
那甚至有怎麼做個強反彈
回檔切入
因為強勢股不想追高
我怎麼做回檔切入的技巧
其實就避雪啦
其實大多數都屬於避雪
因為你要做漲停跟跌停
這個機率比較偏低
但是我們這種盤中轉強轉落
這避雪 因為每天都遇到的
每天都遇到
因為有時候可能強勢股
可能當天開高走低
所以常有的事情
因為如果你今天做強勢股
當你開高走低
你可以做一些小價差
為什麼
強制股今天開高走低
我先賣掉
等尾盤
我說說調整
再把它接回來
所以這兩個技巧
是你做這個
職戰經營班必學的
那剩下其實是我們所謂的
那種每天的盤式的推演
比如說你今天說
我今天做台子期的
我今天想知道
明天會漲到哪裡
跌到哪裡
做一些簡單的砂盤推演
找一些支撐壓力
甚至有些老師說想挖寶
想找一些強制股
哇 今天找一些熱門股啊 強制股
運氣 挖到飽了 對不對
挖到飽了
甚至回答一些學員的問題啊
甚至抓一些主題
老師 像飛龍指數幹嘛的
我今天美國會不會降級 降級嘛
那我怎麼操作
怎麼晚上搶便宜
我那指數公布CBI出來之後
會不會急啦
是怎麼做個價差組合的
欸 這個我們可以討論一下
對 甚至經濟數據剛講的
然後怎麼教同學做一些籌碼的追蹤
甚至我們課程禮拜五嘛
對不對 怎麼下週就沙盤推演
你干嘛干嘛的
哎这个都是我们
客厚中去检讨
总之来就对了